hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to learn
about an important math skill that comes
up in biology and other types of science
and that is identifying place values
what this means is that in any kind of
measurement situation where you have a
number for example here we're using 1234
point 5 6 7 these different digits
within the number hold different place
values for example here the one is at
the thousands place the two is in the
hundreds place the three is in tens
place the 4 is in the ones place then
you have the decimal point the 5 is in
the tenths place
note the THS the 6 is in the hundredths
place which also has the THS on the end
and the seven is in the thousandths
place
again with that THS that distinguishes
these three from these top three now
identifying place values when is this
important well it's important whenever
you're using the metric system so when
you are converting between different
prefixes whenever you're doing any kind
of rounding also working with scientific
notation moving numbers from standard
notation like you see here into
scientific notation and also when using
significant figures which plays a
heavier role in chemistry but does have
some applications and biology as well so
that is it for identifying place values
I hope you learned a lot and we'll see
you next time